Welcome back everyone,
it's Charlie. This will be my full She-Hulk
episode 8 video there are a whole bunch of
Daredevil a bunch of Marvel Easter eggs and
references so we'll break it all down if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the episodes careful for spoilers from
the episode if you haven't seen it yet but we'll
start at the beginning work our way through shot
by shot talking about Easter eggs WTF moments
and I'll also explain the future of Daredevil
in the MCU because we do have a pretty good idea
of where he's headed next like he's going to be on
the echo series we know they're going to start
filming the Daredevil Born Again episodes at
the beginning of next year so we won't have to
wait too long before getting way more Daredevil
stuff there were a bunch of references during the
episode two to other bigger movie related things
like they talked about Red Hulk during the episode
they even made a wolverine reference again during
the episode and we just saw him in the Deadpool
3 teaser video that Ryan Reynolds posts of Hugh
Jackman coming back as Wolverine in the MCU but
the actual episode title was Ribbit and rip it
which is a reference to frog man's catchphrase
that he recites several times throughout the
episode mostly to hilarious consequences Frogman
is another person from the comics he's like
another d-list superhero who showed up in a bunch
of different titles in the context of this episode
in the MCU he's just like a regular rich kid who's
kind of spoiled using a super suit to pretend to
be a superhero but they wind up using him as more
of a villain which is also kind of a reference to
his comic book backstory like he's been both a
villain and a hero at different times the actual
cold open of the episode is him recounting the
events of his failed attempt at being a vigilante
with a super suit that he got from the same
person who makes all of she-hulk's super suits
and he wants to sue him Luke because he burned
himself the first time we actually saw shiho
go to Luke we saw him in a brief Cameo scene he
was the guy that was walking out just as she was
walking in it winds up being another big conflict
of interest for her like the time she was forced
to represent Abomination even though he had this
big history with the Hulk in The Incredible Hulk
movie because they keep forcing her to do that
I think this is also foreshadowing for larger
Marvel Phase 5 Marvel Phase 6 movie plot for Hulk
related stuff because a lot of the Bruce Banner
holds stuff that they do in the series is meant to
be teaser for future Hulk movie stuff that they're
doing and it sounds like a lot of of that has to
do with what's happening in Captain America 4 New
World Order because the leader is the main Villa
of that movie obviously a big whole character from
The Incredible Hulk coming back and we have the
Thunderbolts movie right after that so one of
the big theories because a lot of the people she
represents at our Law Firm are villains is that
she'll be the person that Val uses to clear a lot
of red tape to get the Thunderbolts going and one
of their missions will be to take down the hook
and that will be like a huge conflict of interest
for her like she'll wind up helping the people
trying to hurt her cousin Bruce Banner because
next week's episode is the finale like episode 9
is the last She-Hulk episode I think that they'll
tease that because Bruce Banner is coming back
so we'll find out a little bit more about what
he was doing off planet on sakar and what that
movie plot is that they were trying to reference
I think that'll tie in with what's happening
with the Intelligentsia which is a big comic
book villain group that the leader was part of he
was connected to and the whole pot was she Hulk's
blood and them seemingly trying to replicate
the powers of the Hulk like why else would you
want she holds gamma blood I think that's also
why she made a red Hulk reference at the end of
the episode too but the quest question is is it
the kind of twist that's like oh there's another
Hulk but this one's red why else would they need
she-hulk's blood if they don't want to create
another version of The Hulk and they might use
that for a version of Red Hulk Thunderbolt Ross
in the future we also just found out that they're
planning on recasting Thunderbolt Ross apparently
Harrison Ford was the person they wanted to get
to play him which would be pretty cool but I don't
think that Harrison Ford wants to be inside the
MCU so it probably wind up being somebody else
but it just sounds like they're going to have a
version of Thunderbolt raw show up in the future
so they can do Red Hulk eventually the Monahan
store at the beginning of the episode is sort of
like their in-universe MCU version of like a Best
Buy or a Fry's he recites his catchphrase for the
first time in the episode Ribbit and rip it she
breaks the fourth wall to react to Luke the super
suit maker like oh crap and when they explained
that he's a spoiled rich kid and his father is
one of the firm's best clients that's actually
pretty close to his comic book origin in the
comics he was a failed inventor who was supported
by his mother like he never actually did anything
really successful he just stumbled upon the Frog
band suit and then used it to be a vigil Auntie
when she's talking to Luke about her dress he's
literally making it right in front of her like
he jokes by ripping it down like oh fine you're
gonna sue me I'm not gonna make your dress anymore
obviously they resolved that by the end of the
episode she winds up saving him with Daredevil's
help and he agrees to keep making her superhero
suits and other clothing that will work for her
when she's talking to him they also show this
black armor suit again they've shown it a couple
times it doesn't totally look familiar I don't
think that it's meant to be the kit Harrington
Black Knight armor like his armor is created by
the Ebony Blade itself like it literally comes
out of the sword they have a brand new song Under
the She-Hulk title scene and then when they show
up in court Luke Jacobson's lawyer surprise
surprise is Matt Murdoch Daredevil who makes
a whole bunch of blind jokes about not finding a
parking spot which is also meant to set up their
fight at the end of the episode with a parking
garage when he rolls up on top of frogman's green
car and the whole idea is that in this early
part of the episode she doesn't know who Matt
Murdock is she's never heard of him before she
doesn't know that he's Daredevil obviously which
she finds out later in the episode when she takes
the mask off like wait a minute what you're Matt
Murdoch even though he was a little bit lighter in
this episode a little bit more jokey for the most
part the tone of his character the way he talked
the way he acted was pretty on point for the way
he acted previously in the Daredevil Netflix
episodes the quick witty has like the really
quick way of speaking to the judge is similar to
his other episodes she breaks the fourth wall when
he starts his lawyer speak because as he said he
is a really good lawyer how did you just do that
I'm a really good lawyer he references what if
which is obviously the long-running Marvel comic
series and it's a TV series now too I did episodes
for all the season one episodes and I'm gonna be
doing what if season 2 episodes when those start
at the beginning of next year in fact talk about
Daredevil coming back I didn't mention this
earlier but Charlie Cox is also coming back as
Daredevil during the Spider-Man freshman year TV
series which is kind of like a slightly different
thing but Marvel's going to be releasing that I
believe in 2024 so it's still going to be a while
before we see those episodes really interesting he
references the sokovia chords saying that they've
been repealed since the events of Avengers
end game I think this is the first time that
we've learned about this his whole thing about
superheroes not revealing their identities was a
huge part of the comic book Civil War event and
obviously a big part of Spider-Man no way home
which he was just in that was the whole reason why
Spider-Man had Doctor Strange performed the two
different spells to make people forget about his
secret identity she talks about eyes making more
references to Vision Daredevil being blind they
make a lot of these throughout the episode too
mostly in a jokey manner but a lot earlier during
the trial as well on top of all the Spider-Man no
way home secret identity references that they make
during this the whole privacy thing for him is
also a big deal and a reference to Kingpin because
Kingpin spent most of Daredevil Netflix episodes
trying to find out that Matt Murdoch was in fact
Daredevil and I will explain the way they treat
the Canon because there are some Daredevil Netflix
references during the episode too like specific
references to things during the Netflix series
itself not just broad Daredevil references he uses
his enhanced sense of smell to detect the jet fuel
and Frogman suit which wins them the case and then
buys her conciliatory drinks at the lawyer bar
that she frequently goes to near the courthouse
and gives her that heart to heart about being a
superhero as She-Hulk by Knight and helping people
by day as Jennifer Walters kind of like what he
does Matt Murdock by day is a lawyer in Daredevil
by night as a vigilante they have a lot of
references to people leading double lives double
identities because at this point she doesn't know
that he's Daredevil yet like they play that for a
big reveal later in the episode also the funny
thing about the drink that he buys her is that
it's a green drink with a red had Cherry in
it which is a reference to Daredevil being in
a She-Hulk episode like green for She-Hulk red
for Daredevil is hot as the end of the episode
was for the two of those characters them ending
up in bed together I still think that the Loki
series is the spiciest Marvel Series so far just
because of the premise like the whole idea that
Loki falls in love and wants to get with a version
of himself gonna be real hard to beat that they
have a real quick blink and you'll miss it joke
about him being blind because she tries to help
him find his drink and even if he didn't have his
special Daredevil abilities a normal blind person
would totally be able to find their own drink like
they wouldn't need help in finding their drink the
other cool thing during their conversation here is
that when he says that Luke created multiple suits
for him that's a reference to the multiple new
suits he's gonna wear in the MCU this Daredevil
yellow one in the episode is just the first one I
believe he's also gonna wear a version of the back
in black suit and he'll also wear a new version of
the classic full red one all the different series
he's supposed to appear in in the future in the
MCU so I believe the echo series is the next place
he's gonna show up I think that that will be the
red costume and I think in Daredevil born again
he'll wear the Back in Black costume or it might
be the other way around he might wear the Back in
Black costume first in Echo and then the classic
one during the Daredevil board again series when
he says he has his own practice in Hell's Kitchen
that's a reference to Nelson Murdoch and Paige the
new firm that they created at the end of Daredevil
season three on Netflix and because they play the
Daredevil Netflix theme during the episode the
way they're treating the continuity is that it's
mostly Canada like for the most part but they're
kind of reimagining a few things so it was one of
those cases where it's not a hundred percent Canon
but they're basically treating it like all that
stuff already happened in the events of Daredevil
born again for instance pick up after the events
of Daredevil season 3. most of the same characters
are coming back like we saw Vincent d'onofrio's
Kingpin already in the Hawkeye Series in the
MCU he'll come back again as one of the main
villains during the echo series I believe Karen
Page is coming back I think foggy Nelson is also
coming back there might be some other characters
from that as well too like The Punisher probably
gonna come back I believe Jessica Jones is also
coming back as well to and eventually probably
Luke Cage wants his commitments to other TV shows
are done so like pretty much all the Netflix stuff
is coming into the MCU and they're just kind of
reimagining a few things but for the most part
they're treating all that stuff like it did happen
and I'm actually kind of hoping that they keep the
Daredevil Netflix theme song for the Daredevil
Born Again theme song they actually just did
that for House of the Dragon like whole different
prequel series from The Game of Thrones series but
they reuse the same Game of Thrones intro song
they also just did that with the X-Men animated
series theme song too they used it during the Miss
Marvel series when they revealed she's a mutant
and they use it during Doctor Strange Multiverse
of Madness when they introduce that version of
Professor X from the 838 Universe which was meant
to be a version very similar to the version from
X-Men the Animated Series she breaks the fourth
wall again to be horny for him she breaks the
fourth ball a bunch of times in this episode and
a lot of those times are to be horny for Daredevil
they both get the separate calls and that's just
a joke about them both being called away because
of what's happening with Frogman and winding up at
the same place like oh I have to go do work oh I
have to go do work too but they both wind up at
the same place her first stop away is with Todd
who name drops the wakandan vibranium spear which
they want back because it was stolen from wakanda
a long time ago obviously they want it back a
lot of people theorizing that he's also secretly
connected to the Intelligentsia because why else
would he be at that big event at the end of the
episode and he's super obsessed so a lot of people
in earlier episodes when they first introduced him
were kind of suspicious of him you were probably
right to be suspicious of him he also does the
wakanda forever catchphrase making the symbol
too but then she gets a call from Frogman and
she finally wears her super suit which is from the
comics like this is a version of the comic book
version of the suit it winds up going against a
daredevil before she actually learns what's really
going on so they have a funny moment of them going
at each other Daredevil versus Shield just showing
you some of his acrobatic skills against some of
her basic skills because she hasn't quite learned
how to use them in a fight yet like she can kind
of use her abilities like she kind of brawl with
the Hulk at the beginning of the series but
she's not really good working on a team yet
and that's part of what their jokes are later in
the episode when they're trying to find out how to
actually take down frogman's man like Daredevil
trying to tell her just follow my lead because
I've done this before this is your first time I
think part of the idea is that she'll get better
doing that in future series future movies when she
crosses over it's kind of the same Arc that the
Bruce Banner Hulk has been on in the MCU so far
like he starts out making a bunch of collateral
damage he winds up destroying most of Harlem until
present day as Professor Hulk he's a little bit
better about the collateral damage she's kind
of learning those same lessons as she goes along
this version of the yellow costume obviously
is designed to look like his yellow costume
from the comics that was the very first costume
that he wore when he debuted he didn't wear the
red costume till later the way Charlie Cox talked
about the suit he called it gold like he called it
red and gold not red and yellow but she Hulk does
make some jokes about the colors clashing later
in the episode like it looks kind of like ketchup
and mustard together one of the other things you
probably noticed here talking about continuity
from the Daredevil Netflix episodes what stuff
are they bringing forward to the new stuff his
suit is basically the Daredevil Netflix suit with
the added yellow parts to it like it's the same
basic suit Frogman says his catchphrase again on
his way out of the parking garage Ribbit and rip
it and she gets him finally with the Thunderclap
and as she unmasks him in the background you can
see another ad for the Rogers Captain America
musical they have another joke about whether or
not he's really blind which is a thing during the
Daredevil Netflix episodes like Karen Page asked
him the same question like are you really blind
what's going on and he has to explain how his
ability works and when he says I'm Daredevil they
play the Daredevil Netflix theme song like the
gold devil I'm Daredevil when they show you his
Warehouse layer the lily pad obviously frog themed
everything in it is frog themed there's another
QR code you can scan to get a daredevil comic book
they've done this in previous episodes too as well
as other Disney plus series he's captured Luke to
create him another super suit and on the lamp next
to him here there's some classic frog band Marvel
comic book art the suit that he asked him to make
for him is a reference to Iron Man's armor suits
like he says he wants it to have a fancy British
AI system that talks to you that's Jarvis played
by Paul Bettany who is British Daredevil shows off
his echolocation ability finding out who all the
goons are in the building and he also explains the
difference between goons and henchmen henchmen
believe in the cause goons are just there for
the paycheck and obviously when he says that her
heart is beating fast that's because she's super
horny for him when they're standing behind
the sign on the rooftop here it glows red on
them bathing them in red light four Daredevils
trademark color also everything inside is green
so there's a lot of green and red coloring in the
episode green lighting red lighting to highlight
Daredevil and She-Hulk teaming up in the episode
they give him a hallway scene which is obviously
a reference to all the Daredevil Netflix hallway
scenes although this one is super short when she
smashes the second group before he can take them
on using Hulk's catchphrase again She-Hulk smash
you notice in the background of his room here he's
got a Batman bat signal made to look like a frog
he's got a bunch of frog-related pop culture like
there's a frog's only parking sign there's Frogman
artwork in the wall designed to look like Marvel
comic book art he's got a couple frog themed video
games the Frogger one is a real video game but the
leapfrogger one I think is fake that they created
for this episode but you notice on the screen it
looks like his comic book costume so the idea is
that he got the idea for his costume from the
video game they make more lawyer jokes about
frog man's path out of this without serving
more serious jail time because they're both
lawyers when Daredevil says he's a fan of legal
dramas that's a joke about the She-Hulk show and
the Daredevil Born Again series because both
of them are lawyer shows she breaks the fourth
wall to be horny for him again and LeapFrog says
his catchphrase again as he jumps out the window
injuring himself she makes a joke about devil
being so Broody which was actually a thing in
real life like people talking about Daredevil
and broody before he debuted on the series and
how they were going to handle him in this episode
which is a little bit more comedic and obviously
they pay things off with them getting it on what
he says they should go out when he's in town again
that's him saying he is coming back but he's gonna
cross over with She-Hulk in future episodes again
like She-Hulk season two but I think the idea is
that if Shield crosses over into Daredevil Born
Again episodes that would be her traveling to New
York City because I think most of those episodes
will take place in New York City and if they do
She-Hulk season 2 it will take place in the Los
Angeles area again so it'll be Daredevil coming
back to Los Angeles they have the morning after
joke with him walking out of her place down the
sidewalk in his suit when she breaks the fourth
wall saying she's surprised that we're still here
it's a joke about people only watching the episode
for Daredevil so like what are you still watching
the episode for if Daredevil's gone she gets super
meta too when she talks about the structure of
Television like oh wait is next week the finale
like she starts talking about the final episode
in her referencing a big twist at the end of the
season like oh is this the big twist and she's
also talking about a cliffhanger because the
episode ends on a cliffhanger so this is also her
realizing that she's a fictional character inside
a television show which she did in the previous
episode when she asked someone beyond the camera
like a Kevin feige type of person in real life
to do another previously on changing the plot
of the episode itself like she kind of broke the
episode temporarily to affect the plot Nikki also
calls her a devil for having such a good time with
Daredevil she continues breaking the fourth ball
she mentions Red Hulk like would a red one show
up that's a reference to Intelligentsia the people
trying to get her blood Hulk King and obviously
what they might be doing with Thunderbolts in the
future initially in the comics Red Hulk was
Thunderbolt Ross and the Intelligentsia was
responsible for turning him into Red Hulk which
is why I say there's like a connection between the
intelligencia She-Hulk plot in the episode and red
Hulk eventually she makes a reference to fridging
which is the practice of basically killing off a
character permanently usually a female character
Nikki also jumps out with her brushes like their
Wolverine claws between her fingers which is a
reference to Wolverine coming back into the
MCU in Deadpool 3 which they also referenced
earlier this series with a web page referencing
a guy with metal claws getting into a bar fight
so because they created this episode a long time
ago it sounds like they've known about Wolverine
coming back into the MCU for a long time they pay
off her big dress at the party they bring back her
parents Todd is also there like I said very sus
that he shows up there probably has something
to do with the Intelligentsia and the whole side
joke with the award here is that it's just like
a token a word like it's not meant to be special
she thought that she was the only person that got
it but a bunch of other women got it including the
Mallory book character who's her co-worker at the
law firm then predictably intelligencia hijacks
the big party here but what they basically do
is dox her and it pays off the Josh scene from
the previous episode when he slept with her and
cloned all the data on her phone and all these
records are like her basic internet history so
it's like all of her information being doxed and
it sounds like the reason why the Intelligentsia
the Hulk King character is doing this is to make
her so angry that she loses control and go goes
full Savage She-Hulk from the comics and they
use that opportunity to get her blood because
they still haven't used those special syringes yet
you also notice when they're accusing her of all
these things like you see these two people here
accusing her they talk about her stealing Hulk's
gamma power the red Hazard lighting at the end is
also meant to be like another Daredevil reference
because Daredevil episode just in general the
masked man in the back recording this on their
phones obviously are part of Intelligentsia and
this guy kind of looks like Todd but the hair is a
little bit different and he's not wearing the ring
so it might be somebody else but I think part of
the idea is that a lot of the people that we saw
in earlier episodes will wind up being connected
to Intelligentsia so a lot of the people that are
behind this are people that we've probably already
seen but I also think in a larger sense that'll
have something to do with what the leader is doing
in Captain America 4 and in the Thunderbolts movie
the officers that tried to arrest her at the end
with these special weapons here are damage control
as well if it wasn't clear the new end credits
that they added for the episode are Todd trying
to buy that vibranium Spirit the wakanda auction
against it turns out frogman who wore his costume
also to the auction there's Daredevil and She-Hulk
in bed together and then Daredevil the morning
after walking down the sidewalk past Nikki there
is no traditional post-credits scene I'm expecting
one in the finale though so like next week episode
9 is the finale they'll wrap up the Intelligentsia
She-Hulk plot on a smaller level but they might
spin it up for something bigger because the Bruce
Banner Hulk is coming back and a lot of what he's
doing during the series like this whole Space
plot with him going back to sakar is meant to
be connected to a future movie plot that they were
trying to tease so we think they'll end the series
teasing more of what that Hulk related movie
plot is and we might also get a valpost credit
scene where she tries to recruit Abomination or if
something else happens with the Thunderbolts but
I am expecting Abomination to come back in the
finale as well if you spotted any other Easter
eggs or references in the episode that I didn't
talk about in the video just write them Below in
the comments in my full She-Hulk episode 9 finale
video we'll post next week after they release it
while you wait for everything everyone click
here for my new Deadpool 3 Wolverine trailer
video and click here for that new black panther
wakanda a forever trailer video in Easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!